chair we're ready to start now
thank you good morning and welcome to
team ridge district council's virtual
planning committee
on tuesday 27th october 2020
i'm your chair mike haynes all
participants here today are taking part
remotely
and the committee is being viewed online
and recorded
so please bear this in mind throughout
the meeting
in the event of a break in the internet
connection or a power cut
please bear with us as we try to
reconnect
if we are not able to reconnect after 15
minutes the meeting will be adjourned
and reconvened at a later date please
check the committee page
on our website for further details
please make sure all microphones are
muted when you're not speaking to avoid
any background noise levels
please keep your points short and do not
interrupt when someone else is speaking
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic
blue hand and wait to be called
all councillors have been sent the
agenda for today's meeting
any members of the public who want to
view the agenda
can do so by visiting our website
teamridge.gov dot uk
i will now start the committee by doing
a wrong call of everyone here present
when you hear your name please confirm
by saying
present right chris please
thank you chair um councillor bradford
president councillor bolovant
president councillor clarence president
councillor carl clough president
councillor hugh cox president
councillor hayes president
councillor hook
[Music]
prison councillor jeffrey
cancer dewhurst
present but i'm not on the committee i'm
here to speak
to the tree items
[Music]
[Music]
mcgregor present
councillor nuttall president
councillor nutley president
councillor patch president
councillor parker president
councillor goodman bradbury present
and councillor haynes present
thank you um during today's meeting
there will be public participation to
those who have pre-registered to speak
when it comes to the vote chris will
read out members names would members
please say if they are voting
for against or abstaining
may i be recorded as being present here
but obviously i won't get a vote because
i'm not on the committee
no i think the position is if you are a
substitute have you been
put in as a substitute then you are you
act as a normal committee member
if i may do so thank you chris can you
clarify that
that council gribble was notified as a
substitute
um i haven't been told that council
gripper was
substituting oh okay i i i'm i wasn't
clear i thought that that was what was
said
chairman i should also abstain from
voting yeah i would like to make a
presentation she's done on the the bubby
tracy item
thank you thank you right the officers
present today
we've got ross eastman the business
manager
anna holloway a senior planning officer
gary crawford planning officer mark
wadhams
the senior arboricultural officer chris
morgan
who's been involved already the trainee
democratic services officer
and trish corner democratic services
officer
right moving on then to the start of the
meeting
item one apologies for abstinence please
chris
thanks chair um that's councillors jenks
and telstra's kurzweil
thank you item two minutes of the
meeting
of the last uh committee uh those are on
pages three to eight
uh is it your wish that those are signed
as a correct record
i've not heard any anyone raise
injections so charles has
raised hand uh propose and uh sorry
councilman that'll propose councillor
parker
i think seconded um okay
can i have a show of hands for sort of
um agreement with that please
yeah that that appears um okay right
thank you that's carried
right moving on then to item three is
just in case we need to have that
resolution there but it's not going to
be relevant to any items on the agenda
today
item 4 declarations of interest please
if members could indicate with their
blue hand if they have
any interest to declare
no okay item five public participation
there are two speakers sorry i i did
raise my blue hand for i used to
declare as as portfolio holder
for sport leisure recreation open spaces
etc
i won't be voting on the uh dallas
warren
um planning application
okay thank you that interest is then
noted
like no other hands that i can see
raised so um
on public participation there are two
speakers on the
application for bobby tracy and i will
invite them
at the appropriate time to speak
um item six is the applications for
consideration so we could move on then
to the first of those which is
dualish and i think that's gary
um doing the presentation on that i'm
going to take
this okay um
if you could just confirm for me that
you can see that please claire
yeah can you turn your sound up slightly
please i can see the picture and just
sounding a bit check i've got my wand in
the right place i'm quite likely to have
that
sticking up in there thank you is that
better
yeah apologies thank you uh
see if i can get that out of the way
um so this is an application um for the
change of use
uh essentially of uh two parking spaces
um
in the car park at the dallas
countryside park
um for the sighting of a concession unit
um the uh location uh just off the a379
um at the uh entrance to the countryside
park
uh is shown on this overview plan and
then in in more detail you can see that
it's at the far end of the car park
within the site and we've got a couple
of photos here that show that it's close
to the access gate
and that also shows the screening that
is becoming more established the
hedgerow planting
screening boundary screening along uh
there and there would be essentially a
loss of two parking spaces
um while the concessions stand is cited
uh there this is a proposal that's come
about as a consequence of
um our uh southeast devon european site
uh mitigation strategy work um which
members may be familiar
um is a uh joint
um project that is undertaken between
us and east devon and exeter city
councils
where we work together to make sure that
we can mitigate as much of the
recreational impact
of human activity on these special areas
at dallas warren
on the x estuary and the regulation led
the uh partnership executive uh resolved
that this was a good idea to provide a
small amount of additional funding
um i think it was in july this year so
this application has come to us as a
consequence of that
and it's before you today as um we
considered that
uh overall this is it hasn't been called
in by members this is one that i've
brought to you
as it's on our land team bridges land
and we thought that in this instance
uh in light of the the public interest
in the proposal
it merited um consideration by committee
um but there's nothing particularly uh
unusual or complicated or or
controversial about the proposal we have
had some concerns raised about
um management and littering but again as
a site that's within our control and our
ownership um
uh we would hope that those matters
would be able to be dealt with
and there are a number of conditions
supposed to be applied as are set out in
your report
thank you chad okay thank you right well
the
ward members i see councillor goodman
bradbury
is the one that's present today and i
know she's had a message from council
wrigley so i'll hand
over to you first of all please council
goodman bradbury
thank you um this is uh this is a
a wonderful resource that we have in
dualish the country park on our
doorstep so to speak there has been
quite a bit of interest in this from the
public
um but also i have a message here as
mentioned from councillor wrigley
he's been in touch with the southeast
devon habitat
regulatory partnership um and they are
approval
approve of the idea of the concession
but
really only on the basis of a condition
of a trial
perhaps for a year there are also
concerns
as rose mentioned about litter um
and it's my thought that maybe we could
think in terms of an alternative to
plastic could we is that something we
can condition
or something we could ask for the
concession holder to
um be aware of as this is such a special
site
um from that point of view um and i note
also that
the our town council dollars town
council asked for monitoring of litter
and the impact
um and appreciate that this obviously
could be working with the park wardens
but
um the real problem here is is the
potential of litter i think
that's all i have to say thank you okay
thank you
um yeah i'll ask ross to come back on
that i mean because
whilst i understand the points that are
being made uh we are
landowners as an authority so i'm not
sure whether the planning route is the
best one to take or not as far as those
particular issues are concerned it's not
down in the
recommended conditions so perhaps roz
would like to
comment on that for us please yes
certainly and in relation to
the type of materials that are used by
the concession i think that is something
that would be better specified through
our
lease um as landowner um with them
and littering conditions are one of
those things that um
we occasionally try to impose on on
takeaways and other outlets but they're
very difficult to enforce
it's very difficult to know whether or
not somebody has brought their coffee
uh to this site from somewhere else and
dropped it or their chocolate bar has it
come from this site or has it come from
somewhere else so it's
it's something that it's very difficult
to um to
draft and then follow up on in relation
to the tests that we have to comply with
in relate for
um uh conditions so we do have sympathy
with
with the concern um but it's something
that is very difficult for us
to um to manage and i think it's for
that reason that we
have ended up not proposing a condition
um
for this one there is a um supporting
statement at 3
14 in the report it talks about um waste
and recycling facilities will be
provided um uh and
you know there have been those concerns
considered but
um we just don't think the the
the imposition of the condition is the
right way of dealing with this issue
on this site um although i understand
um the concerns that have been raised
okay
can i come back on that just quickly um
can i ask
about the um the idea of a a trial
with a lease for a year or something
like that for the for the ability for
the
authority to review um the progress of
what's happened
with the concession but we can do that
as landowner
regardless and it's not a planning issue
i don't think but again roz can
can guide us on that thank you so the
proposal that has come
to us is for a permanent um provision
um if there are significant concerns
about the
um on this on an ongoing basis then i
would suggest that the lease is the most
appropriate place for it
um the uh report uh from
the habitat regs uh exec committees uh
quoted in the report at 3
7 where they talk about you know what is
what is important about fangs and they
also refer to the president
at poole where the um on the dorset
heath
where there is a sangs that has been
established that does have a cafe
um it is only a modest facility and it
does
uh you know in the report they note that
the
um facility should not be should not
compromise the use of the site as a park
but
overall on balance the committee as i
understand it
um did decide that um
this should be given the go ahead and
should be
given the opportunity here obviously as
landowner
you know we well as landowner we have a
degree of control
and also as a partner in the habitat
regs exec
program the last thing we want to do is
is do something that takes away from
all the positives that we have at the
fangs the fangs is incredibly important
to us as part of our strategy
of diverting dogs in particular from
doris warren and giving people somewhere
where they can go that isn't the beach
that is an alternative so if that site
becomes less attractive
because there's a coffee outlet there
then we would take that out
away you know there's no questions asked
it's our prime concern
as an you know overriding concern as an
organization rather than my concern as
representing the local planning
authority
is to deliver mitigation that works and
if it didn't work we would stop doing it
um you know i it is i think for the the
lease to be carefully constructed to
allow that to happen rather than for
planning
um to a giant interfere with that at
this stage
thank you point made i just wanted to
raise that thank you yeah okay
so that's that's um councillor mcgregor
thank you jay um i just wanted to check
that we
will um ensure that the concession is
restricted to two parking spaces only
and
that the entrance to the gateway will
not be blocked by
materials associated with the with the
uh
the concession itself and last the last
point i wanted to raise was
has material consideration been given to
the potential of increased
carbon dioxide production from cars
running engines where the weather is
inclement
and people have purchased coffees to to
drink
because i'm going to assume that we're
not going to allow tables and chairs
uh to be dotted around the car park for
people to sit on
as we see occasionally in bakers park
from the the concession that
the lady runs there um
and i think from from the for the last
and third point
have we have we done an assessment of
what the impact will be
on parking as a result of having
concession there
will that mean that parking spaces are
blocked for longer and restrict access
to people
coming into the park
okay ross so if i take those one at a
time
um we are only granting permission for
two parking spaces to be used by the
concession
anything beyond that um you know
incidental
de minimis structures on the site would
be something that would be controlled by
the lease
or be controlled by the landowner um i
can't uh imagine that we would take
enforcement action against somebody
putting up an a-frame but it is
something that we could
uh consider through other powers that
the authority might grant
um likewise we can't stop people from
sitting in their car and bringing a
flask of coffee at the moment
and sitting in in the cold weather if
it's a bit windy uh with their engines
running
um i don't think that that sort of
unregulated emission is something that
that we have any control over or that
should be a material consideration as
part of this application
um the site is well located for people
to
um do walk or cycle to if they chose to
although maybe you wouldn't cycle there
with your dog
um so there are lots of opportunities um
but that hasn't been taken into account
in
in this application um and thirdly um
uh we as as i've previously mentioned we
you know we are the operators of this
park
um it is something that uh has been
taken into account in considering
whether or not this is an
appropriate proposal uh whether or not
there is sufficient
parking i can i have not been uh given
any evidence that suggests that
uh the stationing during the daytime
hours of a um
small scale coffee concession here would
lead to such a problem and a crush with
the the car parking that it would lead
to
any um anti-social parking problems
elsewhere and
it's not something that i've got any
evidence on thank you
thank you councilman natalie thank you
chair
um i think it's a great asset for team
bridge i mean i often drive out from uh
ashburton with our dogs and take a
lovely walk around the old park
um i'm just wondering obviously
parking spaces but is it not at all
possible to actually have this unit just
inside the gates rather than actually
taking up the parking spaces
it might be possible but the decision
has been made that this is where the
the um we teambridge would like to put
it and this is the application that's
come before us
and as the local planning authority we
don't have a problem with this location
uh so the recommendation from offices is
one of approval
thank you councilman clarence
uh thank you chairman um you'll see i'm
holding up my coffee mug now
uh i mean i'm a bit worried about uh
we're encouraging people to go to this
lovely country park
and encouraging to have a cup of coffee
there doesn't seem to be any provision
for
any toilet provision there and that's
worrying me
uh greatly uh if you want to see great
use of this
now i i i do go to places like bakers
park
obviously where there's no toilet
provision i go walk to the salty dog
cafe
where the back of the cafe there is
provision for a toilet
there in the sort of concession so it's
mixed feelings so
where do you go if you if you want to um
go to the toilet
do you not think we should have put this
concession out
with uh advertising it that the
concessionaire
must provide some form of toilet
provision we'd still be making
a profit nothing against that but maybe
we wouldn't be getting in the
extra amount of money because the
concessionaire would have to provide
toilet provision
i think we should be if we can encourage
this
park to to be a majorly used part we
should have a toilet provision there
that's my thoughts and i'd be inclined
to vote against this at the moment
until i knew there was some toilet
provision there thank you
well i don't think that's the sort of
valid planning
reason and actually there's the
landowner issue i'll ask roz to comment
please
so maybe the lack of toilets will
discourage people from having a long
stay in their car and running their
engine while they drink their coffee i
don't know
and you know there are there are
facilities available um
i know that most supermarkets don't mind
if people use the toilet so that there
is an opportunity there perhaps
people to go to sainsbury's and then
there are also public toilets available
at dallas warren which isn't um
especially far away or in in dorlishtown
centre i think there are still some
some publicles so there are
opportunities nearby for those who do
come here by car
um this is supposed to be a
suitable alternative natural green space
we are trying to
strike the right balance between
providing facilities and also providing
somewhere this is a simple opportunity
for people to walk their dogs
um as councillor haynes said i don't
think the lack of public facilities here
would be a reason to not grant planning
permission
and i uh from my experience with uh
learning about uh suitable alternative
natural green spaces
uh the the more i won't the
rustic's not quite the right word but
you know they're more uh
basic the facility the more likely it is
to provide an alternative to dog walkers
rather than being somewhere that people
take their families and
and then you and potentially run into
the conflict between the various user
groups so keeping it relatively
streamlined and straightforward
um can be seen as a benefit for for
these
particular parks for these purposes um
so i
yeah i i don't think that it's a reason
to not grant planning commission at this
stage
thank you councillor bullivant
thank you the principle of having a
refreshment facility on this side is
obviously
i think something which the community
would uh welcome
what i am concerned about is the lack of
control within the application or the
paperwork
that specifies what type of unit is
going to be located there and i note
under
clause 3.8 the uh
no detailed information has been
provided about the unit
i presume it's going to be a caravan
type of unit as opposed to a permanent
structure although this
doesn't specify the type of structure
it's going to be
put in place but what i wouldn't like to
have
is a an industrial type unit that you
see in the
four courts of places like b and q in
the center of what is a
jewel in the crown in terms of the
location of the country park it should
be a suitably designed or suitable
unit of suitable appearance it would fit
within the location and i think that
sort of control
should be exerted by the planners
through a condition
that would or seeks to approve the
actual type of unit that is going to be
put in place
if we're not careful we can end up with
a secondhand converted caravan that
looks like a
well looks a mess which does detract
from the
amenity of the area so i'd like to see
that as a condition
that the actual design of the unit must
be approved by our
planners before it's installed thank you
thank you ross well we're granting
permission here
for here or what we're recommending is
granted permission here is
just the change of use of land to allow
the stationing of a unit so it would
need to be a temporary and a mobile unit
um i i don't know
who the proposed concessionaire is i
don't know if we've gone out to market
on that at the moment
um but i don't have any particular
concern
um about uh you know asking for details
of the unit um
uh to be submitted to us in advance um
uh as again you know we are
uh the landowners and the leaseholders
of this site and i can't imagine that we
would be wanting to put
a uh unsuitable unit on the site
um but i don't have a problem with
just double checking that through the
application of an additional additional
condition
if that would um you know enable members
to to
move towards approval of this one
if that's the case i'll be very happy to
recommend as is without additional
caveat so
an additional condition about the um
actual details of the
structure or mobile structure to be
approved
by planning correct okay i'd be happy to
second
thank you right so it's been obviously
moved the recommendation with that
additional condition
and that who was it second did it please
was that i did
sure council nutley was it john yes
yep okay thank you right so we've got
that noted thank you i've got um
councillor parker yes everyone seems to
jump in just before me council boulevard
i was
going to do the same thing a great asset
and i think it would be a welcome
addition so
i would have proposed it but i'm
certainly in favor of it
okay thank you right so i've got three
hands still up those can all
come down please you've all spoken i
haven't got anyone else
indicating that they wish to speak
that's not already spoken
from those hands in which case um
what we have then is the recommendation
with the addition about
the um details of the structure of the
mobile structure to be
agreed have been as an extra condition
have been moved and
seconded so we'll go to the vote please
um if members can when their name is
called out by chris
uh the motion is for permission to be
granted with those conditions so if you
could say for
against or abstain please when chris
reads your name out
over you chris thank you chair
councillor bradford
four councillor bullervant paul
councillor clarence mitch dane
how's the cold cliff oh
councillor cox councillor hayes
four councillor hook
[Music]
that's the jeffrey council mcgregor
abstain councillor nuttall
[Music]
councillor nutley councillor patch
councillor parker four councillor
goodman bradbury
four and councillor haynes
four make a chair that's carried in
favor
okay thank you there's nobody against
thank you so that's
that's carried right moving on then to
the next item which is bobby tracy
that's item six
b we've got two public speakers for this
one
uh chris so we need to ensure that they
are in the meeting before i continue
with this please
[Music]
okay
okay i can see that the objector is on
the screen
and the supporter is also there and
currently muted
so unless rose has anything sorry
and has anything to say i'll take the
public speakers now
are you happy for me to do that hannah
i think we'd like to just explain the
application first if we can
chair um and uh oh yeah i forgot
yeah we've got yeah i forgot the order
sorry i've got it written down there
okay so if i um ask anna to go through
that with us and then
i'll ask the public speakers to speak
and we'll have the
objector first and then the supporter so
the objective you could mute in the
meantime please and then i'll come back
to you
once and holloway has gone through the
application
thank you
thank you chair i just asked ross
eastman to bring up the actual
presentation for me bear with me
i just i'm on my way
okay so this is a hybrid planning
application
for 63 dwellings including
20 affordable dwellings which is a
policy compliant 30
and then outline consent for three
self-build
units on the site which is phase one
of the allocation bt-1 in
bobby tracy here we have the location
plan
um the the area between
monk's way and morton hamster road and
existing dwellings at
um at bobby this is the the area of the
site
which includes phase one in the middle
phase two to the north and phase three
to the south
let me get the next slide
i'm gonna end the shape and do it this
way
so there it's um we can see the phase
one in the middle
phase two to the north and then phase
three which is also known as bonsmeadow
to the south the uh phases two and three
although shown within an illustrative
master plan for the site
are not included in this application so
they're only shown illustratively at
this point this application would not
grant consent for those developments
the the three custom builds are at the
the front of the site which i saw in the
previous one
in the green the um
the site also includes existing property
at theme park which would be demolished
as part of this
application the layout has been designed
to retain as many trees as possible on
the site
um and has been amended in accordance
with the
um comments of the of the tree officer
um although he would want to have seen
the retention of the populars along the
north boundary
this is about corridor through the site
and
the applicant has applied to remove
those
popular as part of the scheme however
they are looking at replacement planting
through there and the establishment of
a new route and the um which
for the bat corridor which will also
include the
um planting of fruit trees and the
replacement of the existing conifers as
well
because of the the need to keep this is
a dark corridor the connection to
phase two is shown as a as a cyclone
pedestrian link rather than a road link
through there
we can see in the here we go so that is
the
the hedgerow through the middle of that
shot um is
is where the back corridor route would
be and then there'd be a pedestrian
cycle link
through the middle there which is the
dotted purple route
so we have the um south brook lane which
is public right of way which runs along
the southern boundary through the site
down onto monks
way and then across the south brook lane
this is a an old historical route
um which connects atway farm which is
this building
to the right of the screen to south
brook farmhouse which is off to the
yes we're we're rather indicating now um
this is a at the moment the existing
dwellings do
back on to that so we have back rear
garden boundaries there
and really the there has been a balance
with this case
try and improve that route retain it as
a biodiversity route
um and also from a historical point of
view to ensure that the dwellings can
front onto that and connect onto it but
then
it doesn't also detract from from that
route as well so the proposals do
include
some resurfacing and would want to see
drainage works faster
as well there is an existing pedestrian
link through to the houses to the south
which
shown as the dotted purple line
and there's also to the this very
southern
point of the application site there is
shown as a pedestrian and cycle link
into phase three so that would be the
bondsmeadow site
that is not part of the current
application it is only showing a
connection through to that site
and obviously that when that comes
forward a future date as part of that
we'd expect to see
connectivity onto the existing road
network there and also to the south as
well
i think we can just move through the
next couple of slides
that shows you the actual application
site itself and
[Music]
we have the so this is the actual layer
to the proposed development we have
a landscape clearance who come in
and as you come through the site there
is a central
landscaped area which is the retained
hedgerow and trees there
and that would also provide the
place-based provision
i've discussed that with the with the
tree officer and subject to the
obligations and conditions proposed
for the proper maintenance and
management of that area and also to make
sure that the relationship between the
trees
and the play equipment is properly
designed
that uh there's an arb cultural method
statement um for the
provision of that play space it's
considered that that could provide a
suitable play environment um it's also
well located within the site
and there's a secondary area of open
space to the
to the north or around a mature tree
which is to be retained
that's more of an informal space
designed around that tree so there is
obviously provision for
for various um open space on the site
[Music]
here we see the there is a an area a
courtyard parking
and this would include some of the
affordable dwellings in here as well
the uh just where the cursor is now that
is a
a two-story building containing four
flats so
it's not really a block of flats as such
but they are dual fronted properties so
you have
properties facing onto the south and on
to the north so the area
onto that courtyard is well overlooked
and there's landscaping proposed but
there's also
some overlooking to the south onto the
right of way
this is just a bit more of the detail of
the scheme um
you can move through to the next slide
that will show
you the location of the affordable
dwellings
they're a mix of one two and three bed
properties they'll be rent plus
um the custom build plots
are policy compliant to five percent
which is three plots on this site
and there are a range of sizes so
there's some flexibility there in terms
of the
of what the properties coming forward
would be
at this stage there's only indicative
layout within those plots because they
are all
outline only for now
[Music]
this is the southbrook lane
this is public right of way um this is
showing some of the
existing surfacing here there is a bit
of issue with the surfacing and the
drainage in this area
which um which this scheme would
um hope to address and so that should
improve the route
with um some work to the hedgerows along
there
so to really to make sure that that
doesn't become
a back eyelet between between two two
parts of the
two housing sites so we really want to
make sure that that is an appropriate
route particularly given its historical
um
historic importance
this is the central play space and um
it includes a number of different
activities and also the opportunity for
children to interact with the existing
natural environment there
so this is the hedge bank and the trees
and there is fencing around that
and accesses through from the footpath
link there
so this is the northern boundary of the
site so this is between phases one and
two
and this shows you the landscaping
that's to go in there to replace
the existing popular trees there so it's
uh
really to improve the biodiversity of
that and
also to ensure that an appropriate dark
corridor is maintained for the
bats
we have a few sea street scenes now um
the the mix the properties are render
um brick and reconstituted stone
um the the ones on the entrance of the
site are
a mix of render and brick which is more
appropriate for the character the area
we've also had the provision of of
chimneys within that as well to give
that
mixed roof scape
we've got some
okay through i think we've got an image
showing the connectivity of this
site
so this shows you the the blue dotted
route is um the existing
which is the existing footpath link and
then
the routes through the existing housing
development and you can see the school
school there and i'll see through to the
town centre
so this is the existing property at dean
park this would be demolished as part of
the scheme
the access would be altered it would
quite be in the same location
but then a lot of the trees on the
frontage there between the
the new access point and and
the existing edge of bobby tracy
would be retained as part of the setting
and the entrance into the development
so here we can see a view towards back
towards
bobby tracy and that is the the listed
farmhouse on the
on the left-hand side that's actually
farm in there
this is the existing um public
right-of-way this is
south brook lane um this is showing the
relationship it has at the moment so
we would uh would hope that this would
be improved as part of the works
proposed
for this route so we get better
servicing
and some works for the landscaping as
well
this is a central path to site this is
looking obviously towards
the national park and you can see on the
other side you can see the
hedgerow which will be retained running
through the site and also the
landscaping
and through the tree belt alongside
monk's way through there
so this is the um the most northern part
of the application site and we have the
northern tree belt you can see the
conifers and the trees there
on the right hand side that would be
where the the new
planting will be going into to replace
that existing to retain a
back corridor and a vegetated route
through there
so this is the phase two this is outside
the current application site
so this is on the on the other side of
the uh northern boundary hedge
and it's showing the the landscape out
towards
the national park this is a more open
part of the site
but this isn't part of the current
application it does form part of the bt1
allocation though
and this is looking back towards the
application site which and
you can see the row of popular trees
there which would be removed
and the new planting will be established
along that boundary
and then we just have views of the site
from monk's way
so here you can see that it's monk's way
itself is in a cutting
and there's quite a lot of landscaping
between the two
we've got a mature tree belt in there
now
and then we have the this is the public
right away
it is stepped up from monk's way to
south brooks lane
within the application site
and then we have a picture of the this
is the pedestrian link through to south
brook road
and then we also have a
an image of the southern part of the
site so it's looking south
okay that's that's it the officer
recommendation
is for planning commission to be granted
subject to
the obligations set out in the
committee report that would also include
a monitoring fee for those obligations
and also the conditions set out in the
report
thank you chair okay thank you um
right so i'll take the public speakers
next and um
if um chris or trish can correct me this
is a major application so
it's up to five minutes that each
speaker has i believe
yeah thank you and the sound should
happen at the end of the time to alert
you to the
time being up so if i could ask the
objective please first it's richard
you'd uh unmute and uh
you can begin at your leisure
thank you very much yes i'm richard gray
my wife and i
live in a property uh adjacent to the
bt1 site
uh purpose of me being on here this
morning is to encourage the committee
to take account of the objections
to this scheme raised by the town
council
80 or 90 local residents and the
national trust the national trust
objection is important because
they own the site to the south and
they've made it plain
they're not putting any planning
application forward
at this stage so that influences uh
burrington estates
application um
i i've lived in bobby tracy for 30 years
i recognize that
well-designed developments can deliver
the housing that is needed
um and help the local economy
but actually this this application in my
opinion
is flawed uh on a number of grounds
i would say the 80 or so objections have
been lodged
the vast majority are not
anti-development but they are
raising legitimate concerns about
particular issues
which the applicant has not addressed
probably that the main objections are to
do with
the local infrastructure not keeping
pace with development in the town
uh there are two large developments in
town one is completed
one is about halfway through um
and you know they are big developments
about 500
properties between them but the health
center the local school is for
full capacity and let's talk about uh
children in bobby tracy having to go to
other schools outside the town
and the second objection that i raise
and a number of others have as well is
around
bt1 being an important habitat
for foraging and roosting bats
particularly in relation to the south
hams
sac uh a lot of the routes through b2b1
are important flyways and although
uh at this stage there have been some
mitigation
things put in place uh a lot of it is
still conditioned
and that really ought to be part of the
detail in the application in my opinion
uh there is a bat roosting theme park
house
and clearly that will be lost when the
house is demolished to make way for this
development and the access that goes
with it
but up to this stage the applicant has
not
provided sufficient detail to mitigate
any adverse impacts on this protective
bat species uh
a really important issue as part of this
and it's recognized in the report to the
committee
is that the applicant has failed to
produce a viable master plan
for the entire site the site they wish
to develop
is is a piece in the middle uh
as the planning offers officers
suggested that the
peace to the north and the national
trust area to the south
uh and barrington estates have
no control or land purchase agreement
uh over either of those areas
and the national trusts have flagged
this quite strongly in their objection
[Music]
the problem is that there is no
adequate provision in the application
for safe walking and cycling route into
town
the route shown just now by the purple
dotted line
comes up through an existing estate part
of that route
has no pavements there are then six row
crossings
uh to get you into town
and if you're going to have another 160
people living on this site that's a huge
number
uh that will be using that route and
it's really quite dangerous
and i think it's inevitable that people
will walk out the site
onto moreton hampstead road uh into mary
street where for probably 500 meters
there is no
no pavement and it's single carriageway
in places
the the lack of a master plan for the
whole of bt-1
is an important issue again raised by
the national trust
uh it means it's not following policy
for bt-1
uh past that policy was that there
should be a master plan
uh and it's really odd at the moment
that
access you know that's time accessing
the town from this side
actually follows a path to nowhere
because it can't get through the
national trust land
okay thank you committee to refuse the
application please
thank you right if i could ask the
supporter now please uh it's darren
please to put your microphone on and
then you can speak
thank you good morning chair members my
name is daryl summerfield and i'm a
consultant with
lrm planning and i'm speaking today on
behalf of the applicant burnington
estates
burnt united states were an
award-winning devon-based developer with
an established reputation for building
imaginative
and high quality homes the company pride
themselves on exceptional standards of
construction
and the satisfaction of their customers
they've recently been accredited
the highest rating of five stars by the
home builders federation
satisfaction survey whilst involving
developments across devon and the
southwest
burlington estates do not use standard
house types that are rolled out
regardless of the location
every one of their schemes is
specifically designed to reflect the
local character
and utilizes a range of materials and
details that are appropriate to the area
you will not see the same houses
proposed here on another
scheme in any other part of the county
as members will be aware from their site
inspection in february
technically this is a complicated site
topography trees ecology heritage
drainage
landscape impact access and connectivity
uh have all been considered in detail
as is the case with many developments
there have been areas where compromise
has been required
and this is something that the committee
will of course be familiar with from
their consideration of other schemes
the officer has provided you with a very
thorough overview of the key
considerations
given the reasons that the application
was called to a committee by councillor
kurzweil
i would though like to provide a brief
summary a brief summary of how those
issues
have been uh addressed in the
application
firstly the highway authority do not
object to the proposal on grounds of
vehicle or pedestrian safety
or traffic generation there will be
connections provided for cyclists and
pedestrians to both the existing network
and other phases of the allocation the
applicators
applicant has also agreed to make the
improvements requested to south
brook lane the site has a number of
significant trees to the boundaries and
within
and the applicant has worked with
officers to strike a balance between the
retention of those trees
and developing a site that will result
in an attractive and safe environment
while making efficient use of the
available land this is detailed in the
officer's report which confirms that an
appropriate balance has been struck
the application is also considered
heritage issues and these matters have
been subject
to extensive discussions the scheme has
been revised to ensure that it
appropriately respects the heritage
assets
in accordance with the requests of
officers
as you'll be aware this site is
allocated for new homes this is not a
speculative
proposal the applicant is following the
local the adopted local plans guidance
and is working with the plan led system
whilst a challenging site the council
were of course aware of this when they
decided to allocate it
the technical issues will have been
thoroughly assessed and it would have
been clear at the time
that there will be a need for compromise
for this site to come forward
a mix of housing types and sizes will be
provided including affordable homes
accessible dwellings and self-built
plots
this site is included in the council's
five-year housing land supply
contributions have been agreed towards
school transport and travel vouchers and
the council have calculated the sale
liability
for the site exceeds one million pounds
this can be used to support the delivery
and improvement of infrastructure in the
area including schools highways
public transport green infrastructure
has been fully considered and this
proposal will secure improvements to bat
flyways
and it does include a replacement bat
roost so that's a specific part of the
proposal
the the the biodiversity related
elements the scheme would be thoroughly
considered by the council's ecologist in
natural england
and approved by both whilst the site
does not include in the employment
development the proposal will of course
support
employment during construction and it's
recognized that new development provides
further
indirect economic benefits in terms of
sustainability
the proposal currently provides for a
fabric-first approach this will deliver
a 36
co2 reduction by means of improved
insulation and minimal thermal bridging
the advantage of this of course is that
it stays with the building for the
duration of its life
renewable technologies are advancing all
of the time and burlington estates are
committed to exceeding the 42
requirement by the addition of pv panels
or heat pump technology
along with ev charging points the
overdue update on the building
regulations will help to inform which
technology
is most appropriate to be used
in conclusion the applicant and the
project team have worked very hard with
the council to revise and finalise this
scheme
despite the constraints we've presented
a proposal that will deliver high
quality homes
and an attractive place for people to
live the proposal accords with the
council's policy which allocates the
site for residential development
and the officer's report is clear in its
recommendation
burlington estates are ready to commence
construction at the soonest opportunity
and to support the continued delivery of
new homes in team bridge
and we respectfully request that members
support the recommendation
and grant planning permission this
morning thank you
all right thank you um okay i'll ask
council gribble in a moment to speak as
the um local ward member
members will note that they supported
made reference to the site inspection
there was a site inspection back on the
27th of february
obviously yeah a while ago now but
before lockdown so
we did go on site if i could just remind
the members it's on i think it's about
page 4849
apart from myself there was councillor
hugh cox council of bradford
and also present those that are in the
meeting today council of patch
and nutley so if those members
particularly wish to
come in and say things after council
gribble then
i just remind you of that okay council
gribble please
thank you very much chairman uh i i
think the resident raises some
valid and serious concerns but
personally i agree entirely with bobby
shady town council views
um concerning highway safety
concerns around access
to phase one from monk's way turning
across the traffic on the a382
and already now already a narrow section
of rule in addition
the generation of increased traffic
along mary street
is very narrow with very few passing
places
um private highways concerns are
expressed over the
amount of private highways proposed i.e
non-county council adopted and the
number of houses
served from them requiring residents to
take their refuse
to and from the highway for collection
the inadequate infrastructure has
already been emphasized but the planning
statement makes reference to the surgery
makes a reference to available
facilities such as banks
there are none in bobby tracy a primary
school and doctor's surgery have for
many
years been already at capacity
public transport there is a lack of
public transport serving this particular
area of the parish and a lot of trees of
course
concerns raised over the amount of trees
affected either being
pruned or removed and the effect on
listed building the development
will have on a negative impact on the
neighborhood listing buildings
um namely the atway cottage and the
aquay
network cottages and yet ray farm
affordable housing the application
refers to a target of 30 percent to be
delivered
councilors are concerned in bobby tracy
that this is the only only target and
may well
not be achieved i think if minded to
approve
rigorous conditions should be imposed
protecting the remaining trees etc on
site
and to ensure the delivery of affordable
housing
so that local people may be able to
continually
to live in the town and of course to
ensure that the local infrastructure
is improved and increased to accommodate
the existing and ever-growing
population needs i think the speech of
traffic uh
above joining bobby tracy from the
morton amsterdam on the a382
is in excess of that required um
barrington estates have um respected
history
and and i thank them for the
presentation but i would ask that they
take notice of the needs and
requirements of the local people
thank you chairman
thank you okay i've got um councilman
nutley
uh indicated to speak
thank you german as you say a long time
ago since uh
nine months ago now and that um yeah so
i've got a lot of concerns about this
development
and we've heard about the bt-1 i mean
would we have accepted bt-1 as a
development
site now um with consider the impact in
environment
landscape as referred to as far back as
10 years ago
in the 2010 inspectors report
in those 10 years the wildlife has
flourished even more so
and the flood risk has increased
significantly
whereas affordable element is positive
there are huge number of mitigation
elements that must be
put in place by the developer we do as a
planning authority
have the resources or do we have the
resources
to monitor and enforce these mitigations
and conditions effectively
will those mitigations offset the damage
that will undoubtedly be inflicted
on the environmental and ecology will
the mitigations affect
the results downstream where bubby tracy
already experiences
significant flooding there are
significant holes in the current report
the issues of bat flights and foraging
land for bats is not
addressed as adequately nor
is the issue of more potential flooding
downstream
the impact on the national park has been
glossed over and there has been no
discussion with the national trust
or consideration of the impact on the
ecology
on the adjacent piece of land there will
be significant tree loss
at the time when we are seeing ash
dieback and a lot of trees habitats
across the countryside
the national health have already
objected due to the severe lack of
capacity
on page 26 which i feel very concerning
um under open spaces um the play area is
located below
trees i had the unfortunate uh was i
lost my father through
being killed by a tree when i was six
days old i would not want to see
children that
this is as it states in there this is
not an appropriate
because we you cannot have this type of
play equipment
with such as location the play areas on
the whole
uh whole of the located within the close
to the trees and root protection zone
while it is well it is nice to enhance
and make the most of the site's features
play areas
need their independent play activity
area and green buffer zones
i mean we we could go on with grand zap
i i feel that is totally in the
appropriate place to be in
on that i mean when you read the
representations
i mean on on nine there has been there
has not been
a comprehensive bat survey um
moving on to 10. without the full
ecology assessment the bespoke greater
horseshoe bat mitigation plan for the
entire allocation
mitigation measures in a con combination
in impacts on insufficient and comply
with policy bt-1
no foraging area is proposed for greater
horseshoe bats
on 14 concerns regarding impact on
wildlife including
protected and priority species on site
and the loss of habitats
it will not achieve the net gain in
biodiversity
on on in number 33 lots of trees and
excite
the existing trees should not be felt
which i totally agree with
before new trees have been matured
moving on to the uh on number 62 the the
planning permission for development on
this land has been refused
especially and especially twice on this
occasion
uh the affordable element although like
councillor gribble was saying
30 and the councils of the uh
um bobby tracy council
obviously very concerned that that will
not be achieved
i feel that uh to me this this
application
to say i i i could not uh
support it on the present state and i
feel that uh
i think we need to listen to uh other
members for their views as well
thank you chair thank you i see that
the members that are on site have
indicated now so i'll go through those
and then i'll coming myself
at the end um councillor patch
thank you chair i won't run through
um the great many um sort of items that
have been raised as concerns
um i do thank the local resident um
councillor gribble
and councillor nutley for um they're
very very eloquent setting out of the
various
reasons um
having attended a site visit i i did um
make a sort of note at the time that it
is a very wildlife rich area
um it's a very good habitat for all
kinds of foraging
or mammals as um in in addition to the
um the bats
um i am sort of concerned about sort of
any sort of
this sort of suitability of any
mitigation measures
i i think that that there are although
i'm not going to list
all of the objections that we've put
forward i just highlight a couple that i
do find um
quite sort of um concerning firstly the
the infrastructure issue the fact that
this school
and the health center is over subscribed
um the extent to which it does meet the
needs of local people this
application i'm not sure whether there
has been a local needs assessment
um there's been lots of development in
the area already
but the access issue again the issue
raised by the national trust
regarding access and safe routes into
town i just feel that there's a lot here
that is just too concerning for me to
be minded to approve this um i just met
making it also i think there are three
ward members
in this award i do thank councillor
gribble for coming and giving his views
and and representing those of the town
council it would have been nice to have
had
a steer from the other um sort of ward
members on this
you at uh point and explain that the
other two ward members have
actually got an interest and i know one
of them couldn't be here today anyway
it would appear so it's not that they're
not interested
in coming but they're actually unable to
is is my understanding okay i i
understand that interest can prevent
voting i'm not sure that um they prevent
speaking on the um matter
um but no that's it really i'm not going
to
run through the list of objections but i
do find it um sort of like significantly
concerning really that the list of
issues here
that haven't actually been addressed
thank you
council bradford
thank you um i did go on the site visit
and i've got a lot of concerns about
this
application um
the access is really
difficult in fact i would say quite
dangerous there's no
pavement um
i don't know what the bats are meant to
do while the trees are taken down
before the other ones are established
and
i think demolishing dean park is such a
i think it's a travesty and and there's
even a bat roost in there
um i know
that it's a fact that the children in
buffy tracy
several of them have had to go to other
schools outside of the town
um it's just
not right that um
there should be some more houses built
and the infrastructure
isn't there um
mainly a lot of the wildlife
you know the um bats the
badges door mice it it's just such a
wonderful place for wildlife
and i i feel really sorry that they
should be
um destroyed though i do have loads and
loads of concerns about this thank you
councillor cox
sorry getting unmuted um yeah i'm not
gonna repeat everything
it's just i find it's quite surprising
application you can go through it
and pick so many holes in it you could
sit here for half an hour doing it
i think the main thing is wildlife
trees flooding access into town
[Music]
as the previous speakers have all said
i'm quite surprised to be honest that
was that this was ever
considered as a suitable for development
in the past but
um i in its present form i can't see
um it needs too much work doing on it
personally
to get over all the issues thank you
thank you um well i was the other member
that went on site back in february
uh coming at it from the perspective
that it is
an allocation in the local plan and
clearly i i
was looking out for any specific things
on the site visit that would
make me concerned that uh
reasons why it couldn't um go ahead in
the form that it was being proposed
because there's the principle that it's
actually
um for development having been allocated
and i couldn't see any reasons
on site as to why what was being
proposed
wouldn't be acceptable um i think on the
slides we saw
the footpath link at the
southern end of the site that takes
would take pedestrians through and
cyclists
through to the side road
network taking them into town rather
than going along
uh the main or the you know the local
main road
that provides the access into the site
having heard the issue about the land at
the south it was phase three
um you know sort of that not coming
forward there would still be access
through
along the um along the minor roads
that would give access albeit there
would have to be crossing as the
public speaker uh the objective
said so i wasn't concerned about
that aspect of it um having driven there
and looked at the
highway from which the access to the
estate would come
and also from monk's way i again didn't
have any
concerns from the site inspection that i
undertook
as far as the issues that have been
raised also already
about the schools about the wildlife
and so on um i think these points are
all answered in the report
um i mean as far as the school's
concerned it's the
seal money that um that will be used to
increase the
the schools uh devon county uh have
obviously got their comment in the
in the text as far as the wildlife is
concerned we have the
views of our um our own
wildlife staff plus natural england
um when councillor natalie was going
through
the list he was reading the list of
objections rather than
what had been put in uh by people who
are consultants or
professional staff so there were a
number of points there which were just
sort of
personal views which wouldn't
necessarily stand up
i recognize that there are concerns
about the wildlife and it is a wildlife
rich area but
it is an area that has been allocated in
the local plan
so that that would be um something that
i would
um you know sort of have to accept
as far as the the health center is
concerned and the points in the report
it does give a response to the nhs
request for a contribution and where
such would be appropriate
um but there are other funding streams
based on population
and so on so that isn't um necessarily
the the sort of
thing that this has to um provide for
because um at the local plan stage that
wasn't something that was was included
then
and there is the national funding so
from my point of view
the site i couldn't see anything on site
that would raise concerns
uh for the development before us not
happening
and i feel that all the uh objections
have been answered in the text so that's
the position i have
um i'll ask anna perhaps to come in
and actually give a specific detail on
some of those points
that have been raised already such as
the education
uh highways wildlife and so on if there
are any points that she wishes to
to make in addition to what i've just
said so anna would you like to please
thank you chair um i just want to also
say that we've had
three further late objections to this
but they don't raise anything additional
to the points already
addressed in the report um in terms of
the
education i think it's already been
stated that this scheme would provide
um towards the sale contribution um
which is then used for school funding um
the county have asked for a contribution
towards
bus school transport uh which the
applicant has um agreed to pay so there
would be a contribution towards
providing those that school transport
but in terms of education provision
that is something that's covered by
still and therefore um
would need to come out of the facile
contribution made
in terms of highways the
county highways have looked at this and
in terms of the traffic generation and
the access
and haven't raised any concerns with the
safety of of those
or the traffic generated from this
development
with the wildlife um there's been an
approach
appropriate assessment undertaken on
this site there's a proposal for a bat
roost to be provided
and also the in terms of the northern
boundary
there is a phasing with the planting
scheme there to ensure that there is a
continuous
route for bats migrating through that
area
part of the planting there includes
fruit trees and to try to increase the
diversity of the
of the vegetation on site and increase
the insect numbers which then provide
bats
feeding opportunity um the in terms of
uh door mice and other licensing natural
england obviously would need to be
that there is the licensing process to
go through separate planning
um which also affect the the replacement
batch roost
um
i think that was all the points i've
missed anything chair
okay well if there is anyone can come
back um i've got canceler hook next
please
thank you um yeah i just wanted to raise
uh um some concerns
um and ask some quick um questions as i
go along so
i'll uh you know
ask the questions and maybe give leave
it to the end to answer them
um uh firstly the issue of the
comprehensive master plan so i just
wanted to
i mean obviously there isn't one so i
wanted to ask uh that doesn't conform
with policy bt1
why that hasn't happened because just
because there's different landowners
doesn't mean that's not possible and as
i understand it our policy is
if um the developer isn't bringing
forward the
master plan then it would be us as the
council that would do it so that was one
of the questions
um on carbon reduction um
it the report tells us that the
development does not conform to policy
s7
i've read the um what they call the
energy and sustainability statement
and they admit as well that it doesn't
and um
refer to our policy as merely guidance
it's not guidance it's a policy um and
we require
applicants um to divide by it
although i do accept obviously that this
application came in before
our tightening up with our carbon
calculator but nevertheless we do have
and did have a carbon calculator which
they should be
conforming with and i hear what the
applicant said in terms of
you know we don't know what current
technology is etcetera etcetera
um we don't know what it is going
forward but we do know what it is now
and so i would personally be asking for
a deferral to get that detail um
bottomed out it's a bit questionable
that this application has been around
for so long
and that statement itself was january
and we haven't got to a point where
we've got a bit more detail and that
policy s7 is conformed with um
number uh um electric vehicle charging
we do have a policy that would require
electric vehicle charging anyway so
that's policy s9 of our local plan
does require that to be um part
of the application irrespective of its
contribution to carbon reduction
um as i understand it so that's another
query
um so that's about understanding in
condition 24 of the application so it is
referred to in condition 24
but that word and isn't very clear as to
whether um electric vehicle charging
will be required so we just want that
word in explained
um and then the whole issue of
sustainable travel provision
so i can see the footpath going through
into what i think is
south brooklyn um i sort of vaguely know
that route through it's a bit up and
down in terms of walking or cycling
and also i presume that little footwear
link would not be a cycle
way because it would be considered too
narrow so that doesn't allow for
cycling to go through um so cyclone
provision is
essentially nil i mean you're either
going on a road that has
you know already said is a bit up and
down single carriageway got lots of
parked cars etcetera
or else you're out onto the main monk's
way again with no provision at all
so i don't see any cycle provision here
at all um
there's a public transport again you
know i'm not wondering why there isn't a
contribution
required to public transport i i'm just
a query i don't know how good the bus
service is but
um uh doesn't seem to be too much
consideration of it
um then there's the speed limit on
morton hampstead road
which is a 60 mile per hour speed limit
i'm wondering whether
i know in previous applications we've um
asked the applicant to
fund a tpt ro not the tpo
to reduce the speed limit limit or do
works on a road
um and i'm wondering why we are not
asking for section 106 contributions
for sustainable travel um not
all of it needs to come from still as i
understand if it's required to make the
application or development
acceptable then we can ask for it from
section 106
and certainly when it comes to cycle
provision if we're going to make it
acceptable from that point of view
i don't know why we're not asking for it
from section 106
then the one other people have mentioned
also i'm concerned about is the
recreation play areas
um and the fact they're under trees and
if it requires more space to be
allocated for
um play areas well then that's that i
would have thought with what should
happen
and also a query on whether all the
percentages are being abided by in terms
of percentage space for
different age groups and also space for
active recreation
um whether all the um required
percentages are being abided by in this
application i'm not sure
and then lastly the reconstituted stone
sounded a bit
nasty i have no idea reconstituted stone
might look very nice but
um that was the query um why why we're
not insisting in design terms on
on granite limestone and genuine use of
stone
um and what what the carbon
impact of reconstituted stone is as
opposed to
natural stone um so a whole range of
issues i'm
concerned about um my gut reaction
would be to be asking for a deferral on
some of those more important ones like
carbon reduction etcetera thank you
thank you i'll ask anna to come in a
minute on your last point i would have
thought that quarrying limestone and
granite would be far more carbon
intensive than reconstituting
what essentially would be seen as sort
of more waste and
easily accessible material but anna
would like to come back on
those ranger points please
thank you chair um in terms of the
carbon reduction
i think we heard from the applicant's
representative today that
they are baiting on a fabric first
approach
but they do also intend to include
renewables and easy charging points
the proposed condition would be worded
so that they do need to meet
the um the policy compliant level
and we would expect to see details of
the renewables
and of the charging points coming
forward
as part of the scheme
in terms of the um reconstituted stone i
have to say that
i don't know the difference in the
carbon footprint between the
reconstituted stone to quarrying a stone
but i think you're probably correct that
there is a
there'll be a carbon requirement for the
quarrying of it
we would require them to submit samples
of the materials proposed as part of the
um as part of the application and that
is something that
that's a fairly standard condition and
we would expect to see
for this scheme
[Music]
so the bus services the
sill was based on the provision of bus
service as part of the sil
contribution uh so that when you're
looking at what obligations are
requested
then we need to make sure that we don't
um end up with
um requiring something which is covered
by
a different form of
contribution such as the sill so we need
to make sure we don't do something
called double dipping when you're asking
something twice
so for that reason um it wasn't seen as
being
appropriate to um to also have an
obligation for a contribution towards
bus services
um in this instance so because the
play area under the trees the um the
design of that
is conditioned and there will be
obligations on there to ensure that it
is maintained appropriately
and that you get the acceptable um
the relationship between the the play
equipment and the trees is acceptable
for both the trees long-term health and
also the safety of of the children using
that space
so the so the
master plan there is a
there is a requirement in the policy for
a master plan
uh within our um
we don't consider this to be for master
planning purposes we don't consider this
to be a strategic
site whereby the council would produce
the master plan
uh the applicant has provided an
illustrative master plan
um to show how the schemes to the north
and south of the site would could be
brought forward
um
on the basis of the grounds of
prematurity for this application
for the lack of a an adopted master plan
it'd be very hard to justify that
appeal um because the
with the site the last it says um it's
hard to see how you would
develop this site differently and
provide different levels of connection
into the sites the north and the south
given the needs of the back community
corridor
um i think something else was the
flooding off site
um the devon county is the lead like
flood authority have reviewed this and
they are now happy with
the scheme um with the uh the runoff
rates of the proposal
i think ross might want to come in a bit
more detail on the
master plan point okay ross please
thanks anna i think you've probably said
everything i was going to say
on the master plan point um i was just
gonna um
briefly remind members that we have
similar considerations and concerns at
uh whitehill for na2 um and also to an
extent
um at na3 as well um and
uh the inspectorate considered that both
of those schemes um
could proceed with the level of
information that was submitted as part
of the application without having a
formally adopted
um master plan and an a3 obviously is
substantially larger and i don't think
that is one of the
the matters that is a tissue at the
moment and so the absence of a master
plan we don't consider in this instance
is a reason
to not grant planning permission um the
other point that was mentioned by
councillor hook i think was about the
the cycle links
and the extent to which that um route uh
was going to be adequate or otherwise i
think um
uh on the whole um we if i can just
share my screen
we in principle through residential
areas we expect cycle routes to be
um sharing their routes with low traffic
routes and that's the the case across
most of our allocations we don't
always expect there to be an off-road
route and so whilst it is true to say
that this
short section here of existing footpath
is not at cycle route width
and i would have thought that that was a
wheelable length
of route so you could cycle to that
point and then you can cycle from that
point
um on road and to get to the town centre
and the um school if that is the choice
that people make
and so again the fact that there isn't a
dedicated off-road cycle route
here um for a scheme of this nature i
don't think
would be something that would be a
sustainable
concern to raise and i think the other
point that was raised was whether or not
we had sufficient play space and how
that was being addressed through
conditions and obligations
if you can pick that one up
so in terms of the um the amounts of the
open space and the play space
then um that would comply with the
policy so we have
1 700 square meters of natural play area
located essentially within the scheme
and approximately 5 500 square meters of
additional green infrastructure
including the additional area of open
space a green space adjacent to the
access
of moreton hamster road and the wildlife
corridors along the
north and the western boundaries
so apart from the one bed flats all the
dwelling houses benefit from private
outdoor space and um
and so there is there is a range of
spaces
proposed within the scheme um
there is a balance needed between the
different requirements and
we do have a scheme which i know there's
been comments about the
effect of saying a target of 30
affordable dwellings
where this scheme is delivered it is a
full application for that path of scheme
and it is providing
the required amount that forms part of
the application
um so to sometimes you need to balance
out all those different requirements
the proposed the form and the layout of
the
open space in the green infrastructure
here is considered appropriate when
taking into account
all of the different criteria for this
development to meet
and it would it would be providing a
policy compliance level of affordable
housing
and obviously the custom build plots as
well
so this is an allocated site in the
local plan and we do need to remember
that that is the
the principle of providing housing on
this land is therefore
forms part of our of our adopted local
plan and that is the basis for any
planning application to be determined
thank you chair
okay thank you um councillor mcgregor
thank you chair um i note on condition
12
um that it says development should be
carried out in accordance with
the approved plans and documents um in
terms of
you know this is quite a regular uh
position for me to to kind of mention
is that if this pla if this plan is
approved
um that we're not gonna see um
a series of condition variation requests
that will then reduce what was approved
at the time of the application being
approved to something completely
different
and i'm looking for assurance that the
conditions have been set
are achievable right now and can be met
and if they can't
if we can't get the guarantee that they
are achievable right now and like
council hook i would uh suggest the
deferment until we get a set of
conditions that can be
delivered as they are approved
um i think i think what you're asking is
is pretty much impossible because any
applicant can come back and
you know sort of put an application in
for a change in the condition
so um ross do you want to respond to
that one please
i was simply going to say that we have
discussed the conditions with the
applicant team they are
aware of the act of the conditions that
we're we're suggesting should be imposed
and the details that we are requesting
and do want to
to continue to control um but you're
right
we um it's a bit rumfeldian isn't it but
we don't know what we don't know
um and there may be circumstances
downstream
why the developer needs to come back to
us uh and request an alteration
but that that process is one that we
uh follow uh diligently and uh
using our professional skills knowledge
and judgment um and
the one that is open to public
participation so
um unless it's a non-material amendment
an absolutely minor
um they minimize amendment that doesn't
affect the the quality of the scheme
there will be public consultation
on those changes and there is an
application process there that we have
to follow
but there may be legitimate
circumstances why changes are needed and
we don't at the moment know what
what those might be um likewise with the
106 requirements you know we
we absolutely consider at the moment um
everything that is in that package in
that in the proposal is deliverable and
achievable we have no reason to
disbelieve that
and that's part of the reason why anna
uh noted earlier that you know we will
be seeking a monitoring contribution as
well to make sure that we are able
to um keep on top of uh the 106
obligations and
and to ensure that the delivery happens
as we think it should
um but we are not um
we are not super sayers we are not
fortune tellers and can't
can't see what's going to come
downstream um but at the moment we have
commitment and agreement from the
developer
that this um list of conditions and
obligations as before you in
the recommendation uh is is acceptable
to them
um and from our perspective we consider
that it delivers the necessary
mitigation to make this policy
compliance scheme
uh deliverable with the benefits it
would accrue thank you chair
thank you right i have no other people
indicated they wish to speak
um councillor patch's hand's gone up now
on councillor hook so i'll
bring you both in then councillor patch
thank you chair yeah i just wanted to
come back on one point the issue of
infrastructure and sale money um i mean
it strikes me that you children cannot
be pointed towards a figure on a balance
sheet
um for sale money received as an
alternative to attending a local school
nor can elderly people be pointed
towards a figure on a balance sheet
as an alternative to be able to register
and attend a local health center
particularly the last issue a local
health center something that would
affect
my residence in my ward as well as they
would um
so be likely to use the bubby tracy
health center um i
i just i'm not sure about um how this
issue is addressed of a lack of
infrastructure
and money sitting in a sale bank account
doesn't provide that infrastructure
and i'm not sure what mechanism there is
for ensuring that
these services can be provided to um
allow those services to be provided for
new residents in an area
well this is the system that the
government has given us it's the civil
system so that's how developers pay
their contribution
and then the various bodies responsible
for providing those pieces of
infrastructure
are required to do it with the use of
that money or other monies they may also
receive from central government so
i can't see it as in any way a planning
reason for an individual application
that we can
sort of bring it in as part of the the
argument
um i'll ask ross if she wants to respond
to that please
um just to add that i don't think we've
had a representation
from the health center or anybody
representing the the local primary care
to suggest that there is any
uh particular difficulty the
representation that we've had from the
nhs is from um
tool bay hospital and i think the two
need to be distinguished as past the
consideration here
um but yes in relation to education
contributions
the um capital review group um uh part
of our local
you know our our infrastructure delivery
planning processes
um uh does make decisions about where
and when money
is directed towards individual projects
and that is undertaken in partnership
with devon county council we have funded
a new school provision at king stanton
through phil and are also i'm putting
money into the pot at southwest exeter
so if there is a a need and a request is
made and there is a project
then then there is the potential through
the infrastructure delivery planning
process
um for that to be sought
and it's also worth noting that um both
the uh
surgery and um other partners were
obviously consulted during the
preparation of the local plan
and so there and need specific local
needs and requirements that
were made known to us at that point in
time would have been included and
reflected in the plan
um in this instance as far as i'm aware
there is
uh you know no specific request and we
cannot seek contributions where they are
um
going into a bottomless pot from section
106 we have to have a
costed funded identified project that
would deliver the necessary mitigation
just for this development as well
so we can't um much like with flooding
we can't uh ask this development to make
good an existing problem downstream same
with health care we can't ask this
development to make good an
existing problem if there is one at the
surgery and i know that uh historically
there was funding delivered
by the bradley benz scheme i think for
additional healthcare provision
uh in bobby chasey and so it can and
does happen through the planning system
um but that request hasn't been made in
this instance and therefore we cannot
uh not grant planning permission because
of the absence of infrastructure that
that hasn't been evidenced to be
required
thank you councillor huck
thank you just to come back to a couple
of points so on the carbon reduction
um it according to our policy it
shouldn't be conditioned
so policy ent3 says major developments
will be required to produce a carbon
reduction plan
to indicate how this could be achieved
this theon policy s7
and the 42 reduction um so it's it's not
something that
should be conditioned it the plan should
have been produced
and they should be showing how how
that's going to be achieved
so i think we are in our rights to ask
for a deferral and ask how the carbon
reduction will look partly partly
because
whatever is proposed could have an
effect on
how the site is laid out or how the site
appears
or its design appearance so that's part
of the reason
why i would have thought why you would
want to know up front how it's going to
happen
um i just wanted to double check as well
the wording
on condition 24 i think it would be
worthwhile separating out
the electric vehicle charging because
that is a separate requirement which
comes from
s9 of the local plan and so that should
be in there as a separate requirement
for it to be shown
um if there are sometimes there are um
physical differences in the way a site's
laid out because of
ev charging so i think we'd want to see
how that's going to happen across the
site
um and just to refer back as well to
policy s9
um you know it's a it's a subjective
thing isn't it how how much you've
provided for
walking and cycling and public transport
so i can see a link through to an
existing housing estate
um and it's a route to walk to for
example the school
it's not really a route to walk to some
other places
and so one could argue how much is
walking being promoted or how much is
cycling being promoted
it's not really being promoted it's
linking through to an existing route
which takes you to some destinations but
not all of them
cycling there is as i can see no
provision whatsoever i don't accept
being having to walk your bike for a
certain distance is cycling provision
that's not cycling provision
um so i don't see any provision for
cycling so
we could argue that it doesn't conform
to policy s9
because policy s9 point b
says provide and link to strengthened
and improved
public transport cycling and walk-in
networks and i don't see it
linking to anything that's been improved
it's linking to something that's
existing
and those future links are unknown they
may never happen
and we've experienced before at hill
park um
where you can do a phase of a
development and leave people walking
along a main road
this won't happen i accept in this
situation
but um you know we we should have
learned those lessons about
you know doing phases of development
before others and leaving people at a
disadvantage
and discouraged from using sustainable
travel when that is exactly what we
should be doing
um so my my feeling is we should be
asking them for a deferral
to know exactly what the carbon
reduction measures are
and also um on the sustainable travel
i'd like to see
more i mean that's difficult to us to
demarcate exactly what
what more is but i i don't feel there
has been any improvement
specifically to the cycling network at
all
rise did you want to comment on that um
deferment or
or is the condition going to be okay
so from my perspective and i i have
sympathy with um
what counselor hook is saying about it
would be good to have the details
up front on the carbon reduction side of
things but in this instance there's no
doubt from the developer
that they are content and happy to
target
or to achieve uh the 42 reduction they
just
um have been slightly hanging fire to
see whether or not there was a
requirement going to be introduced for
air source heat pumps or x1 z
alternative technology
um so uh we have uh
a plan that demonstrates uh that they
can achieve a significant proportion
of the necessary carbon reduction but
then there's a bit more that
will come in in subsequent downstream
detail and we
if as far as i'm concerned that's a
pre-commencement condition and we would
expect those details um before
a spade was put in the ground uh in
effect um
and i would not have thought that there
would be a need on this site with the
the topography and the arrangement of
the site for any uh
major substantive changes to the way the
site is laid out
to um for them to achieve that that
detail and so
i i don't consider that carbon reduction
is a reason for a
deferral and neither do i think that the
sustainable travel that we have
as part of the application which
includes the travel vouchers which are
cycle or bus vouchers and includes
um the non-mary street uh
safe routes uh into the town centre
which seems a reasonable place to be
trying to get people to
for their onward travel to destinations
or elsewhere
um or to carry out their day-to-day uh
needs in the town centre i think that
what we've got here represents an
appropriate balance for an allocated
site
so i don't think i don't see that
there's any need for deferral at this
stage
thank you thank you council bull event
thank you thank you can i just confirm
with the officers please
this site is a consented site within a
local plan therefore the principle of
development on this side is already
agreed
that the officers believe that the the
spirit
and intent of the policies laid down by
team bridge are met through the
conditions that they've sought to apply
on this site
and that uh all of our statutory
consultees
have passed or their comments in favor
of approval on this site and that
the policy that we have for three
monthly
site meetings as part of the enforcement
procedures for sites with over 50 homes
will enable local councillors to visit
site every three months to make sure
that the conditions
as written are being applied
appropriately
and that they still recommend that this
approval is given for this site thank
you
thank you anna do you want to come in or
is it ross
uh in short i think the answer to all of
those was
yes um i i know that there have been a
couple of reservations from a couple of
our comfortees and uh i think that the
town council probably counted one of our
or do count as one of our statutory
constitutes
uh but in our view the the site
represents the best balance um
of development that we can achieve at
this time for this site and yes it would
be
caught by our enforcement policy because
it's more than 50.
all right thank you councillor hook i'll
let you come back again
just one remaining thing was the um
separating out of the electric vehicle
charging as a separate condition
separate from the carbon reduction
because they fall under
different policies and just to say that
they're some of our internal officers
weren't
weren't all together happy with all
parts of this application
in terms of their comments thank you
roz the separation of the two conditions
absolutely i agree that would help the
clarity that's not a problem and
members will note that the
recommendation uh specifically says the
number
and form of conditions um to essentially
suit how how they come out when we draft
them to make sure that they are
adequately clear and precise
so um i think that would be a one
positive that we could do
yeah for sure thank you thank you well
nobody's moved anything yet so on the
absence of that i will move
recommendation as set out with that
slight
addition of the electric vehicles that
council hud just said
so i'd move the recommendation for
approval as set out
would anyone like to second that please
i'll say a second all right thank you so
councillor parker was the first one that
i saw so that's
uh it's been seconded right can we go to
the vote then please so the motion is
for
approval as set out with that electric
vehicle
edition um and um so you'll
when chris reads your name you either
say for against or abstain please
okay chris councillor bradford
the environment against
councillor bullavant
councillor clarence councillor cole
clough
councillor cox uh against
councillor hayes all that stein on this
one
how's the hook again
councillor jeffrey paul
councillor mcgregor abstain
councilman russell against
councillor nutley engaged councillor
patch
against councillor parker
or council government bradbury
abstain and councillor hands
four okay
we'll just um get the numbers on that
chair that's six four six against and
three abstentions
so it's your casting vote yes that's
that's what i had recorded as the vote
so i'll use my casting vote in the same
way as my original vote and that will be
four
in which case approval is granted
you um i think at that point
members may wish to have a comfort so
have you voted twice then mike
in that case i used a casting vote as i
am entitled to do and i voted in favor
the same way as my original vote so in
which case the vote is carried
by the casting vote and uh approval is
given
right um i think members will probably
want a comfort break before we carry on
that's the usual
um request so can we have
um just a few minutes i'll make it
20 uh 16 minutes passed um
we'll need can i just check with um
chris we'll need to re-register again
won't we
yes sure there'll be an another role
called okay there'll be another roll
call
um so shall we say 25
past then to allow members time to have
a comfort break and then come back
because we've still got the two
three applications and we'll have to go
through that process again
so do you want us to actually log off
now chris to come back
okay if you can just put your cameras on
like pull your cameras off
and then mute your microphones okay
right so we do that so cameras and
microphones off plays and then
um for 25 past
i should be leaving at this stage
chairman okay
um
foreign
uh chris i'll make it 25 past so we're
going to get the proper screen back
please
cool
mike before you start again i seem to
have got a picture of my table in front
of me instead of how do i get that back
do you know chris can you um
sorry council clarence can you click the
arrow next to the stop video
button see if you can change your camera
that you're using
to the arrow next to it
are you using your issued little
computer yes top left hand corner you've
got a
little round circle which says switch
camera
top left hand corner can you see a
little round or we'd say we've got a
picture of a
icon of a camera with two little circles
just touch that in
switches the uh the view from your your
lens
sorry about that thank you very much
thank you thank you
right um i think it's after the time i
indicated so chris
if you could go through the roll call
now please if members could
indicate that they're present please
counselor bradford president
councillor bullet president councillor
clarence
president councillor cole clough
president
councillor h cox president
councillor hayes president councillor
hook
prison
councillor parker i think he gave his
apologies
yeah he did yeah councillor goodman
bradbury
present and councillor haynes present
thank you thank you right um so we're
moving on
now to item seven seven a first for the
tree preservation order
that's it both in nipple pen but it's
the first one uh which is e2 stroke 15
uh stroke 21 so i'll introduce
um mark waddems who'll take us through
this
uh over to you mark uh thank you very
much
uh so this report concerns the
confirmation or
otherwise of the district of team bridge
doing the field lane creepers station
order
uh 2020 which protects the group of nine
beach trees
uh located on or close to the
southeastern boundary of the property
known as
dallach and if i can just share my
screen
so this is the plan showing the the
location of the group of trees
these the trees here looking uh looking
east
so these are the mature uh beech trees
this is it from dawnfield lane looking
north you can see the trees on the
left-hand side there
again same trees looking south the trees
are now on the right-hand side
so they i'll just get rid of that from
there
so the tree fertilization order was
served on the 15th of may
2020 and the provisional protection that
the
uh the order um gives will cease on the
15th of november 2020 if the order is
not confirmed
the truth preservation order was
confirmed following concerns a number of
trees have either been felled or
fallen in recent years and the making of
the
tree preservation order will uh protect
the trees and allow for replacement
planting
to be to be undertaken if trees are
removed in all four in future years
we've received uh one letter objection
and the
projection can be summarized as follows
that the trees are in uh are in a
dangerous condition
and that no advanced notice was given uh
regarding the making of the tree
preservation order
so taking those individually one by one
um the council will look upon an
application
to undertake works to any trees that are
considered to be dangerous
and indeed following the making of the
original pre of the original
tree preservation order an application
was made to fill one of the beech trees
and that was subsequently granted
and that tree is now being filled
subject to a replacement tree being
planted
with regard to advanced natives being
given uh
to the making of the tree preservation
order this generally not
not given to reduce the possibility of
any preemptive filling
being taken so the trees are considered
to provide a great deal of visual
immunity
to the to the area particularly when
entering and leaving hippopotamus
accordingly the recommendation is that
the treat preservation order is approved
unmodified thank you thank you
um so um
ward member councillor jew hurst you've
asked to speak so
over to your please thank you very much
chair um so firstly i'd like to uh just
make a declaration of interest i own
property at either end
of dornerfield lane
and i've probably walked or driven past
those trees
more than once or twice every day for
more than 40 years
so these trees are absolutely
iconic to to our uh to our village
there are standard beech trees
absolutely beautiful
trees and and they have
one by one been picked off by
weather and and decay
over the years so the council
took this uh tree order um when
when tree operatives were actually
chopping down trees um as far as i'm
concerned
as far as i'm aware um no work has been
done to maintain the trees at any time
uh during their during the last 40 odd
years
um and i think part of the problem
um has been the fact that there was a
considerable uh sort of disagreement you
might say
as to who actually the trees belong to
because they are on the highway side
of the of the boundary hedge
of the property known as stalage but i
think everybody is agreed now that they
belong uh to stalage they're part of
stalage
although if you just looked at them you
would think they were part of the
highway
um so that's really uh the background to
it
um as far as i i'm concerned i
i'd really like my grandchildren to see
these trees
and um and if they just get picked off
one by one over the years we lost one
uh in january this year um
at uh at the just to the right
of the second picture that you saw um
and and it was sort of basically
we then had problems uh with the high
winds
um earlier on uh this summer and early
autumn
and that's when the the tree order was
was made
so i would just like to urge my
colleagues
on on on this committee uh to
to to follow that uh recommendation from
our officer
uh and actually uh declare these trees
preserved uh along with many other trees
in
in our village um ipple pen has got
loads of trees i'm pleased to say and
that's because
they've all got tpos on them thank you
very much
thank you well i'll move the
recommendation then um which is
um before one on the text here that
um the tree preservation order 2020
is confirmed unmodified that's for dawn
of field lane
i'll second that a second
okay right it's been seconded okay
um does anyone else wish to speak
nobody's indicated
in which case we'll take the vote on
that then please so it's the
recommendations set out
to approve it so you vote for against
or abstain so chris could you go through
please
thank you chair councillor bradford
councillor bullavent four councillor
clarence
fort councillor colclough
councillor cox councillor hayes
councillor hook councillor jeffrey
councillor mcgregor or councillor
nuttall
or counselor nutley or
councillor patch or council government
paul and councillor haynes
that's unanimous chair yep thank you 14
votes for none again so that's carried
so that
um is confirmed right if we move on to
the
next application 7b um
another site elsewhere a nickel pen and
ask
mark to take us through that one please
okay how's that yeah i can see that
perfect
thank you okay thank you okay
so sorry about that so uh this report
concerns
uh positions to team bridge altoona
number two tree preservation order
uh 2020 the um
the tree preservation order uh was made
on the 9th of june
uh 2020 and the prison law protection
will cease on the 9th of december 2020
if it's not confirmed
the original order was made as an area
designation
and following discussions uh with the
representative and the agent
of the site it's now proposed that the
order is confirmed in a modified version
so instead of being an area order the uh
expose is confirmed i say in a modified
form so this will include 13 individual
trees
and three groups of trees
just looking at the the site from
various different angles
this is specific from the south
uh from the east to look at these uh
these trees pine trees here
and from the west okay
so the tree preservation was made
because the trees contribute
significantly
significantly to the visual immunity of
the area
um three letters of objections have been
received
and the objections can be summarized as
follows
the trees called shea core shade to
gardens and dwellings by restricting
light
detritus forcing the trees into gardens
and also box cutters
and reach from the trees may or do
damage our surface instructures
constructors
structures sorry so these letter
objections have principally
been received from adjacent property
owners
so taking those um those objections one
at a time
the the hardware councils are boring
cultural officer acknowledges
uh concern expressed by the objectives
the making of the treaty preservation
order does not prevent the reasonable
mantra to the trees
accordingly the objectors are encouraged
to discuss their concerns with the uh
with the owns of the trees
and then the council will look upon any
applications that came forward to prune
the trees uh sympathetically
the council's uh broadcast officer as
always is available to assist
uh adjacent uh residents with the
filling in of application forms
if that's uh that's required
so in essence because the trees are so
important to the vision into the area
it is proposed to say to recommend that
the order is
confirmed in a modified form from an
area to protecting individual trees
thank you chair thank you
again um councillor dewhurst has
indicated wish to speak as ward member
so councillor junehurst please
thank you chair sir i couldn't find uh
my unmute button because uh of the
the ah that's better uh the screen's
back um so
yes uh just as with last time
um i mean these these trees are our
important trees in our village uh one of
the great things
in my opinion uh about ipple pen it is
is the number of beautiful trees that we
have uh
in our village and the fact that sadly
when some of them come to the end of
their lives
um we can actually uh insist on on new
trees being replanted
proper new trees not just
a quick whip or something like that and
and that maintains our our tree cover uh
most of the trees in the village are
covered um either through conservation
area or
or specific tpos and and we'd really
like to
to continue that so once again uh please
colleagues
uh let let's let's keep it pen looking
beautiful
uh and i urge you please to support
uh this motion from our tree officer
many thanks
thank you okay
nobody else wishing to speak um
again as previously i'll move the
recommendation that's
um at the top of
all right thank you yeah councillor
patch
thank you chair um i just wanted to um
ask the tpo officer um the the change
from the
area um designation to the individual
trees i think i think that nothing with
13 trees now being protected was
mentioned
what's the sort of net loss of coverage
of
in terms of number of trees from that
that change is it possible
to say i think if we uh if we look at
the uh there's an aerial photograph of
the site here that you can see i think
can you see that
uh yeah at the moment it's not on screen
okay sorry
let me just uh let me see if i can share
my
my screen again
okay sorry can you see that now yes yes
yep so this is the
the aerial photograph of the of the site
so you can see that the
the the the vast majority of of trees
are protected there's some small
uh scrubby little growth here that's
that's not protected so
um so in essence the all the decent
trees uh on the side's going to be
protected so
i think that gives you a rough idea of
what we're looking at
okay thank you okay
all right thank you um so i moved the
recommendation
um is that seconded
i'm happy to second that mike okay
sounds like
yeah there we go okay thank you
counselor goodman right thank you
um okay so we can get the
screen back if uh if nobody else is
asking any questions to look like it
okay then so it's been moved the
recommendation that um the amended
i've got it before me somewhere the um
it's confirmed in a modified form and
that was seconded so can i ask chris to
go through the vote please on that
thank you chair councillor bradford
council bullervant
counselor clarence
sir colclough councillor cox
paul councillor hayes
councillor hook council jeffrey
council mcgregor four councillor nuttall
councillor natalie orr councillor patch
councillor goodman bradbury and
councillor haynes
four that's unanimous chair thank you so
that's approved
thank you thank you to mark right
on to item eight on the agenda which is
the appeal decisions to
be noted um
so that's just a normal list so members
can say that there was a sort of
a mixed bag there and um
there's no no points to
to make on that in which case with
item 8 that then brings us to the end of
today's agenda so
thank you all very much for your
attendance um as it turned out we named
we may have got away without having a
comfort break but you never know with
these things
and i didn't know which where alistair
was coming from so
it may have gone on a bit longer so
thank you all very much and uh look
forward to seeing you all
soon can i just ask the the officers and
perhaps some advice chairman to
hang around where everyone's logged off
just have a quick chat
okay thank